Caption: and so huge thank you to all the
Caption: sponsors into all the volunteers
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: sorry my name is Donna which you already
Caption: know oh I am the head of people in
Caption: culture for igneous aka insight and I've
Caption: been in IT industry since I was about 21
Caption: which no one's give away my age but is
Caption: over 17 Ian's um and I loved fighting
Caption: the street gosh this is dumb
Caption: it's I'm gonna get loud us that you
Caption: probably turned it down a bit the more
Caption: excited I Kenneth the louder is going to
Caption: get in here
Caption: I love the IT industry what I love about
Caption: it is that it's always changing you
Caption: always have to be learning and you
Caption: always have to be looking at what's next
Caption: and continuously keeping up to date and
Caption: I guess one of the points that I want to
Caption: make today is that that is a passion
Caption: that doesn't discriminate but passion
Caption: and love for learning any of us can have
Caption: it males females whatever so merely
Caption: focus everything that you do around
Caption: attraction for females and for everyone
Caption: in your organization focus on that more
Caption: than anything else and why am I here
Caption: today it's not because I love public
Caption: speaking but it is because I'm really
Caption: passionate about getting more famous
Caption: entitiy and Intertek and also helping
Caption: and progress their careers and move into
Caption: leadership roles and that's because I
Caption: believe and there's also a lot of
Caption: studies that back up that the best
Caption: organizations are way more successful
Caption: and I was pretty excited to see that
Caption: this talk to even write quite highly in
Caption: the voting which i think is awesome
Caption: because it means that there's a lot of
Caption: people that are passionate as well and
Caption: excited about the importance of
Caption: attracting more famous into IT
Caption: so these are some of the areas that I'm
Caption: gonna run through today I am happy to
Caption: take that other question throughout but
Caption: I probably will cover a lot of the stuff
Caption: throughout the talk sorry probably best
Caption: to wait till end and I did have lots of
Caption: Q&A time allowed some of that stage name
Caption: to a little bit but there will still be
Caption: plenty of Q&A time I'm also on a panel
Caption: later on this afternoon
Caption: Thank You Aidan and I'm also very happy
Caption: to have a chat about
Caption: to do this later on I'll be hanging
Caption: around for a drink as well at the after
Caption: party so please feel free to coming up
Caption: shop so starting with your advertising
Caption: where do you advertise so most people
Caption: advertise understander places see Korea
Caption: 1 but what it would say is there's
Caption: actually a lot of job boards that are
Caption: targeted towards females specifically
Caption: one of my favorite is BBC job and the
Caption: fabulous dimmer and valaria they're
Caption: winning an award recently and have been
Caption: doing an amazing job at creating their
Caption: organization over the last two years
Caption: what I love about it is a there's a it's
Caption: time to towards females but there's
Caption: actually criteria around who can
Caption: advertise on their job site not just any
Caption: employer can employers actually have to
Caption: go through a process where they
Caption: demonstrate that they are a diverse
Caption: organization and that they've got
Caption: flexibility and they've got culture and
Caption: they've got all these benefits for
Caption: females typically and I think that's
Caption: awesome the other area is LinkedIn
Caption: groups and Facebook groups personally
Caption: I'm more of a fan of LinkedIn groups but
Caption: that might be showing my age again but
Caption: there's a lot of LinkedIn group
Caption: specifically for females
Caption: there's week where there's ICS women
Caption: there's Perth web girls there's Fitz if
Caption: you're in the East Coast there's so many
Caption: different groups so join up to these
Caption: groups network with these people
Caption: you can post things on the wall you can
Caption: you know gain a lot of exposure to a lot
Caption: of females through these groups
Caption: referrals or the other main area most
Caption: companies have great referral programs
Caption: where they you know pay you money if you
Caption: refer someone and it can be just
Caption: forgotten about so what I want to say is
Caption: you need to be proactive about referrals
Caption: if you've got specific roles that you
Caption: want females in your organize to join
Caption: your organization actually go out to
Caption: people and remind them so you know we've
Caption: got this awesome role who do you know
Caption: you know you know any females that you
Caption: think would be interested don't talk to
Caption: the females in your organization and ask
Caption: them to promote it too then it works as
Caption: well and you'll get a lot more exposure
Caption: and have a lot more chance of attracting
Caption: some females there's a lot of studies in
Caption: a lot of you know if you google
Caption: gender-neutral wordings of look
Caption: of research around different wordings
Caption: such as rock stars you know superstars
Caption: high-profile vs. collaborative learning
Caption: focus friendly adding values so be
Caption: careful the way that you write your job
Caption: adverts as well pay attention to these
Caption: things the other thing is highlights the
Caption: benefits that you have there's an
Caption: organization specifically for females
Caption: use your advert as an opportunity to
Caption: really call out this benefit it's your
Caption: opportunity to tell people why they
Caption: should come and work for you you know do
Caption: you have paid maternity leave do you
Caption: offer flexible work options part-time
Caption: full-time etc the other main points that
Caption: I'm very passionate about in terms of
Caption: advertising is criteria all those little
Caption: bullet points every time you put
Caption: criteria on your job advert you're
Caption: basically creating it creating an
Caption: objection for someone not to apply so
Caption: think about why you're putting your
Caption: criteria on your job ad there's a lot of
Caption: studies this is one of them that talks
Caption: about the fact that females are more
Caption: inclined than men to believe that they
Caption: need a hundred percent of the job
Caption: criteria to apply so just be careful of
Caption: creating those objections think about
Caption: using words like desirable or better yet
Caption: think about not using any criteria why
Caption: don't net developer knows what a.net
Caption: developer needs to have to be successful
Caption: for the job right so why do we need to
Caption: put ten bullet points of what they
Caption: should have it's just unnecessary
Caption: the job is an opportunity for you to
Caption: sell your organization why should they
Caption: come and work for you what makes you a
Caption: diverse place what makes you a great
Caption: place to work couple of little examples
Caption: you don't have to read it all because I
Caption: will call it out this was a not-so-great
Caption: example crowded traditional structured
Caption: ad really talks about what you need to
Caption: have and what you need to bring to us
Caption: and if you look at the criteria it has
Caption: words like deep domain experience
Caption: extensive knowledge what does that even
Caption: name I might be a mouth that has cheese
Caption: of experience I'm sorry to generalize
Caption: but there is going to be a lot of
Caption: generalizing
Caption: stuff you probably assumed that before
Caption: you came and listened but there might be
Caption: someone with truth experience and I
Caption: might think that I know everything about
Caption: this subject I definitely have extensive
Caption: experience
Caption: I'm totally applying for that job on the
Caption: other hand you might have let's say
Caption: female who it's not quite so secure with
Caption: their skills and they like you're like
Caption: oh my goodness extensive experience you
Caption: know I've got eight years you know I'm
Caption: pretty good but I think that extensive
Caption: probably means you're an expert and I
Caption: don't think that I'm an expert yet so
Caption: I'm not going to apply for that job and
Caption: you see what has happened
Caption: you just lost people a fantastic advert
Caption: that I found and interestingly the first
Caption: ad that I found on the DC Steve Jobs
Caption: website when I went to it is this one
Caption: here it literally takes every box of my
Caption: perfect job on the first opening
Caption: paragraph is all about why this company
Caption: is excited about the participation of
Caption: women in their organization and how they
Caption: help women gain leadership positions
Caption: it's talking about what's valued in
Caption: their organization and how they're going
Caption: to help a female if they come to their
Caption: organization the second thing I want to
Caption: call out which I love and I actually
Caption: haven't seen this before is their
Caption: criteria it says you can contribute to
Caption: and it really cooled out what you'll get
Caption: to be part of if you come and join this
Caption: organization which I just think is a
Caption: really cool way of putting it and I
Caption: actually haven't seen it before and then
Caption: finally they actually talk again about
Caption: why you should join up what's great
Caption: about us what's great about our culture
Caption: we have inspirational leaders we have
Caption: flexibility you know it's this whole job
Caption: effort it is a massive selling factor of
Caption: why this organization is fantastic and
Caption: specifically why it's fantastic for
Caption: females and after this I'm not gonna lie
Caption: I'm probably gonna go and do a bit of
Caption: research into it cause it actually
Caption: sounds fantastic so then you've got
Caption: these people coming through your process
Caption: and your interview stage now what I
Caption: really want to call out here is that all
Caption: of our natural instinct is to hire
Caption: people that are like us that we get
Caption: along with so we want to work with and
Caption: you know
Caption: to make friends with people who are like
Caption: us that we get along with so unless you
Caption: specifically train your interviewers on
Caption: what they're looking for
Caption: that's what's going to happen what is
Caption: culture fit there's so much culture fit
Caption: it's throwing around all the time and if
Caption: you haven't trained people and what
Caption: they're looking for culture fit to
Caption: someone might mean well they'd like to
Caption: go and have beers after work I like to
Caption: go and have beers after work or they
Caption: cycle I cycle what are cultures it means
Caption: so to me it's around values it's really
Caption: making sure that your interview
Caption: questions are aligned to your values if
Caption: you end up hurting all the same people
Caption: obviously you're going to have a lack of
Caption: diversity but you also going to have a
Caption: lack of innovation or like of different
Caption: ideas alike of different opinions which
Caption: once again studies back up that diverse
Caption: organizations are more successful and in
Caption: my experience that's definitely been the
Caption: case so in terms of I guess some example
Caption: questions that you can talk to your
Caption: interviewers about you know how does
Caption: this person demonstrate a love of
Caption: learning are they passionate about what
Caption: they do how they demonstrated a team
Caption: focus and a knowledge sharing ability in
Caption: their previous roles these are values
Caption: related questions but they need to be
Caption: tailored to your organization
Caption: specifically if your higher values are
Caption: capabilities specific skills can be
Caption: trained
Caption: it doesn't matter of people and missing
Caption: a specific skill that's the easy bit
Caption: from from my opinion and from my
Caption: experience I want to tell you a brief
Caption: story about my fabulous recruiter whose
Caption: actual maternity leave at the moment she
Caption: applied for a role before coming to us
Caption: and it was with one of our competitors
Caption: and she didn't know what the time and
Caption: her colleague also applied for the role
Caption: but she had about six years of
Caption: experience in IT recruitment he had
Caption: about the same in recruitment but no IT
Caption: experience it was in a different
Caption: industry no she went through need to be
Caption: processed and the interviewers were all
Caption: male and he got the job over her which
Caption: was great for me because I was able to
Caption: hire her about three months later and
Caption: she's been amazing and three years down
Caption: the track it's you know she smashed it
Caption: but you know I wasn't a fly on the wall
Caption: for that interview process so I didn't
Caption: know why he got the job
Caption: her but what I do know is that he only
Caption: lasted about six months and what I also
Caption: know is that if those interviewers
Caption: hadn't been trained on what they're
Caption: actually looking for they might have
Caption: just gotten along with him better and
Caption: just go halt I'd like to work with him
Caption: we got along I'll hire him so you need
Caption: to be really careful because you might
Caption: not be getting the best people for the
Caption: job
Caption: speaking of finding the right coach
Caption: again there's some big names up there
Caption: and you know Cindy companies that I
Caption: think coming out of the University all
Caption: of us would have been pretty excited to
Caption: dream of working for and there's a lot
Caption: of similarities with the core values
Caption: that you see things like passion respect
Caption: collaboration quite common and quite
Caption: popular and definitely the values that
Caption: are attractive to females specifically
Caption: when I first started in here the first
Caption: thing I did we had 25 people at the time
Caption: so the first thing I did was work with
Caption: everybody and collaboratively come up
Caption: with what we wanted our culture to be
Caption: and what we wanted our core values to be
Caption: and this meant that everyone was bought
Caption: into it because one person doesn't
Caption: create your culture every single person
Caption: your business creates your culture so I
Caption: ask people you know - we have some
Caption: brainstorming sessions and everyone
Caption: everyone has different styles so you
Caption: need to be careful of being inclusive so
Caption: I asked people if they wanted to send me
Caption: images or pictures or if they wanted to
Caption: send me words whatever worked for them
Caption: you know just give me hits some
Caption: information some snapshots of what you
Caption: want our culture to look like in six
Caption: months time or one year's time or today
Caption: you know and it was it was amazing it
Caption: was fantastic we came up with his five
Caption: core values everyone was aligned to them
Caption: everybody was bought in and then it's
Caption: the behavior that your reward that will
Caption: drive that culture forward it doesn't
Caption: just you know happen without any effort
Caption: so the next step was creating a living
Caption: the values awards program and that
Caption: awards program I'm pretty proud to say
Caption: it's still running five years later at a
Caption: hundred and twenty people and it's still
Caption: as everyone's as engaged as ever so
Caption: every month people can nominate each
Caption: other they can nominate P
Caption: managers can nominate people whoever and
Caption: then we chew and they talk about what
Caption: value their nominating them for and how
Caption: they display those behaviors what
Caption: they've done and then each month we
Caption: choose two people that get a prize and
Caption: we promote the hell out of it on our
Caption: newsletters and on our internal systems
Caption: and also on our recognition programs as
Caption: well and it's been really successful
Caption: over the last five years the other thing
Caption: that we created about two years ago was
Caption: we implemented a recognition program and
Caption: that just organically absolutely took
Caption: off on its own and I think it's because
Caption: we already had the foundation of the
Caption: culture around rewarding each other and
Caption: celebrating each other and thanking each
Caption: other if anyone hasn't seen it it's a
Caption: program called ready and if anyone
Caption: watches the shark tank it's no missiles
Caption: red balloon day business and it's
Caption: basically a program where we allocate
Caption: points every quarter to all of our staff
Caption: so you don't just have to be a manager
Caption: to be able to recognize and you know
Caption: give points to people you can just do it
Caption: peer-to-peer and those points can be
Caption: traded in for things on the red balloon
Caption: day size so you can buy experiences one
Caption: of the females recently bought a whale
Caption: watching trip and she went a while
Caption: watching with her family and then she
Caption: told everyone about how awesome it was
Caption: Kristy down the front that used to work
Caption: for us bought some really cool
Caption: headphones so you know you actually get
Caption: a story out of what people are using
Caption: their points for as well and then you've
Caption: got a recognition wall that calls out
Caption: all of these stories of how people are
Caption: thanking each other and how they're
Caption: helping each other and it just really
Caption: helps reinforce those behaviors again
Caption: and drive the culture do you want to
Caption: reiterate that if you hire the people
Caption: with the right values in the first place
Caption: everything else is a lot easier and the
Caption: other thing I want to reiterate is to be
Caption: transparent and call out behavior that's
Caption: not in line with your values you know
Caption: don't be afraid to call it out and to
Caption: say you know that wasn't in line with
Caption: our values I don't want to see that
Caption: behavior again just be transparent about
Caption: it and if you do that it will continue
Caption: to keep driving that's right behaviour
Caption: flexibility it feeds into culture as
Caption: well
Caption: for females it's important to have a
Caption: flexible culture and once again I'm not
Caption: just saying that this is for females
Caption: only and not for males because we
Caption: actually have quite a few males in our
Caption: organization that do after school pick
Caption: up a forcible pica if the kids are sick
Caption: they stay home with the kids but the
Caption: stats are still that females are doing
Caption: about 70% of it so it is more important
Caption: for females and you do need to really
Caption: promote it if you want to attract more
Caption: and retain more females you know the
Caption: days of working nine to five eight two
Caption: six nine to nine whatever it is they're
Caption: gone in the tech industry and more so
Caption: than ever with cloud access we should
Caption: have flexibility to work however and
Caption: whenever we want and be empowered to do
Caption: that and it's so important that people
Caption: can do that and work from home when they
Caption: need to some examples is that we had a
Caption: staff member who used to do three days
Caption: from work in three thousand office and
Caption: two days from home for child care
Caption: purposes we have another female recently
Caption: who asked to work you know three days
Caption: from the office and then take two days
Caption: to move to a part-time role look if she
Caption: wanted to study Andrea interior design
Caption: why not why not support these things
Caption: what's the downside
Caption: I would argue that you get so much more
Caption: and loyalty and work ethic from people
Caption: if you do have this flexible culture and
Caption: if you are helping people pursue
Caption: whatever they want to pursue up funds
Caption: work when I first started I dig near my
Caption: CEO I had had a few bad experiences and
Caption: he had a blanket rule no one can work
Caption: from home he was so against working from
Caption: home I'm sorry unless you were part of
Caption: the senior management team of three and
Caption: then it was behind but no one else was
Caption: allowed to work from home and that
Caption: really fed into a negative culture
Caption: because of the lack of trust so I worked
Caption: with him really closely around managing
Caption: by exception you know don't let a couple
Caption: of people that are doing the wrong thing
Caption: ruin it for everyone and ruin your
Caption: entire culture during the afraid to have
Caption: those difficult conversations with
Caption: people that are not doing the right
Caption: thing so we changed that straightaway
Caption: and the difference in the culture you
Caption: know was ridiculous it straightaway
Caption: moved to a culture of trust and move to
Caption: a culture of managing transparently
Caption: negative behaviors
Caption: transfer of processes is something that
Caption: I'm also really passionate about about
Caption: everything but it's so so important in
Caption: attraction and retention and once again
Caption: for everyone for males and females but
Caption: certainly for females there's a lot of
Caption: stats that say that females are less
Caption: inclined to ask for salary increases to
Caption: put their hand up and say I deserve a
Caption: promotion give me a promotion
Caption: they're just less inclined to do that so
Caption: we need to be proactive about creating
Caption: really objective fair transparent
Caption: processes so that it's easy for them to
Caption: have those conversations with you one of
Caption: the projects that I've axon edenia was
Caption: creating really clear career pathways
Caption: that mapped into a capability framework
Caption: that was completely objective so you
Caption: could see okay here's a promotion
Caption: whitebook these are the capabilities
Caption: that I need to give examples of to be
Caption: able to progress to the next role and it
Caption: just changes the conversation instead of
Caption: a semi having instead of a semi having
Caption: to say I deserve that promotion they can
Caption: say you know what I've been working out
Caption: I've been working through this promotion
Caption: workbook and I meet all of this criteria
Caption: here's some here's here's the examples
Caption: do you think that I'm ready for a
Caption: promotion it just makes the conversation
Caption: a lot softer and a lot easier for a
Caption: female to have the other thing that I
Caption: was actually quite excited about with
Caption: the inside acquisition of igni and 12
Caption: months ago is that insight have transfer
Caption: of salary bands and once again it's
Caption: about making the conversations easier
Caption: for females to have with their manager
Caption: so by having a transfer at salary band
Caption: it means that you can have a
Caption: conversation about all this is the
Caption: minimum this is the maximum this is
Caption: where you sit on the band and I figure I
Caption: can say well I've got this many years of
Caption: experience and I guess compared to the
Caption: other people in my team this is where I
Caption: think I'd probably sit on the band but
Caption: I'm only here is there a reason for that
Caption: just makes the conversation softer and
Caption: easier to have and in my experience it's
Caption: made a really big difference
Caption: so getting like people go to great
Caption: culture we've got transparent processes
Caption: then you need to promote the hell out of
Caption: it employer branding
Caption: sponsorship getting involved in things
Caption: like this
Caption: sponsoring things that you know health
Caption: of the IT community but also sponsoring
Caption: programs that are targeted at females as
Caption: well I talked about some of the groups
Caption: earlier we were ACS women check those of
Caption: super-heroes there's a lot of programs
Caption: that specifically for females and by
Caption: sponsoring and even bet on volunteering
Caption: and getting involved in them it shows
Caption: that you practice what you preach it
Caption: shows that you actually care about
Caption: diversity and that you genuinely do want
Caption: to help more females get into the
Caption: industry and stay in the industry
Caption: getting involved in events and panels so
Caption: I'm organizing an event for 80s women
Caption: early next year and it's around career
Caption: than I take so I'm getting five amazing
Caption: women with all different types of
Caption: backgrounds and all different types of
Caption: IT roles to talk about what it is they
Caption: love about their role what they love
Caption: about working in IT and what their
Caption: career journey has looks like so all of
Caption: those little things you know feedback on
Caption: your own personal brand but also your
Caption: employer brand as well so encourage your
Caption: employees to volunteer and to get
Caption: involved to be on committees you know
Caption: I'm on too many committees but encourage
Caption: them to get involved because that will
Caption: reflect on your organization give them
Caption: time to I mean that would be unheard of
Caption: for my organization but if you can you
Caption: know give people time to be involved in
Caption: that sort of stuff because you'll get it
Caption: back tenfold meetups as well I know a
Caption: lot of people in this audience will be
Caption: involved in user groups and meetup
Caption: groups and they're absolutely fantastic
Caption: for that networking internships
Caption: University grad programs get involved in
Caption: them as well go don't open days you know
Caption: get the messaging out there as young as
Caption: you can
Caption: Awards so when we placed what we got out
Caption: of the RW that supposed to work award
Caption: which was in my second year adding here
Caption: we got another eight and that was super
Caption: exciting and I think there's the
Caption: difference in the response rate of
Caption: headhunting and in males when we have
Caption: that award and we could talk about that
Caption: award with over 20 percent increase in
Caption: the response rate which is crazy just
Caption: from one award and promoting that award
Caption: so the talk to marketing department you
Caption: know try and get involved in in
Caption: getting those types of awards now
Caption: there's all these diversity Awards as
Caption: well which we haven't gone down that
Caption: track yet but you know thought works are
Caption: doing a really great job of getting some
Caption: of these diversity Awards and I would
Caption: say that is the next thing to make sure
Caption: that you're getting involved and getting
Caption: some of those awards to add toward your
Caption: employer branding messaging and benefits
Caption: you know we talked about on our advert
Caption: talking about all the benefits that we
Caption: have the females put it on put it
Caption: everywhere at all the or all the
Caption: different spots or different things you
Caption: get involved in promotes those benefits
Caption: that you have for females under toe
Caption: story about a lady named coat the she
Caption: was referred to us through Microsoft and
Caption: Microsoft had actually referred her
Caption: through to a lot of their partners and a
Caption: lot of their different networks she was
Caption: the lady who'd been out of the IT
Caption: industry for about 15 years she'd gone
Caption: away she'd had children and she wasn't
Caption: able to get back in she'd been applying
Caption: to jobs she'd had you know contacts at
Caption: places like Microsoft referring her and
Caption: she was just having no luck whatsoever
Caption: and I met with Gail and she was awesome
Caption: you know she was so passionate about IT
Caption: and she was she was studying a
Caption: servicewoman studying she was lecturing
Caption: at TAFE on office programs because that
Caption: was the only type of semi I told she
Caption: could get um I don't mean that in a bad
Caption: way to taste amazing but yeah it was the
Caption: only type of role she could get but she
Caption: wanted to get deeper she wanted to be
Caption: technical again she used to be a
Caption: developer she was too young for her
Caption: career to be over you know she's naughty
Caption: I don't even think she's 50 I don't know
Caption: I'm very bad at age but she was really
Caption: passionate and she really wanted to get
Caption: recognized me and she was getting
Caption: knocked back after knocked back after
Caption: knock back no one wanted to invest the
Caption: time to upskill her again so I sat down
Caption: with my practice manager and I told him
Caption: my dilemma and we talked about okay what
Caption: can we do how can we create an
Caption: opportunity for this awesome lady to get
Caption: into our organization and it took us
Caption: about three months so it wasn't easy
Caption: it's not easy when you're trying to
Caption: think outside the box and try and create
Caption: things but it is important and after
Caption: three months we were able to create a
Caption: power bi training opportunity so we got
Caption: her in as a casual to create some
Caption: training and three months after that so
Caption: in the
Caption: time so she was doing this hobby our
Caption: training and then she was learning and
Caption: upskilling at the same time so she was
Caption: there she was able to do both with the
Caption: cudgel and then after three months were
Caption: able to offer her a permanent role and
Caption: I've helped in RBI team which was super
Caption: exciting and you know she is our biggest
Caption: advocate she is talking about us to
Caption: everyone and she's so grateful and she's
Caption: so excited and she's so happy to be
Caption: working for us and her work at work I
Caption: think is ridiculous and you know exact I
Caption: guess all the thing you have to think
Caption: that bugs got sometimes and there's all
Caption: these women that have moved out of the
Caption: IT industry and we need to be thinking
Caption: about how do we get them back in what
Caption: can we do you know kill should we be
Caption: running some sort of training courses
Caption: and weekends that we can promote and see
Caption: if we can get some women upskilling sort
Caption: of like the industry but want to get
Caption: back in we need to really I think think
Caption: bigger and being more proactive about
Caption: how do we you know get an untapped
Caption: market back into our companies I'm not
Caption: sure if there was an exact approach that
Caption: story but networks
Caption: it was networks Microsoft that kayseri
Caption: networks and networking relationships
Caption: especially in Perth I've really really
Caption: important and then the last thing one
Caption: employee branding is where does the
Caption: first place where do people go when
Caption: they're researching your company to
Caption: website to your careers page on LinkedIn
Caption: whatever that's the first place that
Caption: generally they go so you told me I
Caption: wasn't allowed to do a link because it
Caption: would break my presentation blah blah
Caption: blah whatever so we've got it it's a
Caption: little bit a little snapshot of my
Caption: career size up here and the first thing
Caption: I'm gonna say is don't you stock photos
Caption: why why there's no reason to stock
Caption: photos use real photos of your people
Caption: your diverse people having fun and show
Caption: your culture you know so we've got a
Caption: snapshot of art that's the first thing
Caption: people say when they go to our careers
Caption: paid is a snapshot of our real people
Caption: some of our ex real people but you know
Caption: it hasn't been long time and you know
Caption: you can come back and then we call out
Caption: you know some of our leaders and please
Caption: think about what you're doing here like
Caption: there's only two reason I've got three
Caption: about seeing my leaders on our careers
Caption: page right use the females that you've
Caption: got in your organization as role
Caption: and promote them you know we actually
Caption: call out we are passionate about
Caption: diversity make it really clear talk
Caption: about your awards talk about what
Caption: sponsoring you get involved in you know
Caption: that's our advert for the technicals of
Caption: super-heroes program so just use all
Caption: these things as an opportunity to
Caption: promote why you're diverse and speaking
Caption: of role models once again you know
Caption: without be my role models it is gonna be
Caption: more difficult for you to attract
Caption: females so you get some get one and then
Caption: when you've got one use them for
Caption: everything you know so once you've got
Caption: something from way the hell out of them
Caption: there's so many things you can do you
Caption: can you know you can get little blurbs
Caption: and you can put things places there's
Caption: video blogs you can do there's little
Caption: day in the life of get them out at
Caption: speaking events Christie's gonna be in
Caption: my panel you know really promote these
Caption: women and that will help you attract
Caption: more females of into your organization
Caption: also make sure that someone as part of
Caption: the interview process can really sell
Caption: your culture and sell that you're a
Caption: diverse organization and why and what
Caption: you do and your benefits and even you
Caption: know I was the first face that every
Caption: single person saw so that was you know
Caption: that was an extra benefit because I'm a
Caption: female and if you can get a female as
Caption: part of the interview process that would
Caption: be ideal but if you can't make sure it's
Caption: someone who really understands your
Caption: value proposition and what makes you
Caption: different from everybody else and why
Caption: you've got all of these great benefits
Caption: but you really stick about your targets
Caption: and about your goals I'm not really a
Caption: fan of targets personally but we've got
Caption: 20 percent females coming out of RT
Caption: degrees why would we expect that we can
Caption: have 50/50 in our companies like I just
Caption: think that that's unrealistic so I think
Caption: what we need to be doing is yes let's
Caption: get as many as we can and let's have it
Caption: as diverse as we can but let's all start
Caption: working together on targeting younger
Caption: the younger generations and getting them
Caption: into the university degrees you know
Caption: there's an amazing program could take
Caption: those are superheroes that you can go
Caption: and talk to Michelle about later on if
Caption: you
Caption: so more information on it if you have to
Caption: tell not that anybody wouldn't know you
Caption: but you know every year the amazing
Caption: Jeanine is basically getting thousands
Caption: of girls learning how to code and
Caption: thousands of girls across Australia New
Caption: Zealanders well right maybe yeah amazing
Caption: amazing
Caption: so you know these girls are getting
Caption: together getting mentored and learning
Caption: how to code building an app that's got a
Caption: community benefit so it's you know it's
Caption: a win-win it's your corporate social
Caption: responsibility there as well and I'm
Caption: learning and getting started about I
Caption: team what IT is and what what apps are
Caption: so you know if you haven't heard of this
Caption: program seriously everybody should be
Caption: getting involved in it either as a
Caption: mentor as a judge literally the judge it
Caption: takes half an hour of your life once a
Caption: year it's nothing as a volunteer and
Caption: there's an organization we should be
Caption: sponsoring this stuff leadership roles
Caption: is even less of a percentage of females
Caption: right so we definitely need to be making
Caption: sure that we're encouraging our females
Caption: into the leadership role I'm pretty
Caption: stoked that we now have three out of
Caption: eight it's not quite 50/50 right um you
Caption: know I've had true females into our
Caption: leadership team in the last six months
Caption: which is really exciting for me and the
Caption: extra collaboration and the just a
Caption: slight balance and differences that you
Caption: see in the way the leadership team is
Caption: when you've got a balance is incredible
Caption: it's just so much better and the males
Caption: say that as well the males back me up on
Caption: that and both of these both Karen and
Caption: Laura came to me through my networks and
Caption: through referrals so once again girls
Caption: networks referral networks educating all
Caption: of your employees around the benefits of
Caption: diversity and why you're trying to be
Caption: the best organisation what's the point
Caption: making sure everyone in your company is
Caption: aware of that is really important and
Caption: and what I coach the crises and how to
Caption: be aware of it there's so much training
Caption: now on unconscious bias was not funny um
Caption: you know you can get if you've got
Caption: internal HR you can get it for free
Caption: you've got people that will come
Caption: do lunch & Learn sessions if you're you
Caption: know into tech there's a really cool
Caption: company called diversifying with the
Caption: fabulous Lucy Hammond who's a local post
Caption: person doing virtual reality diversity
Caption: training
Caption: I mean how fun is that presenting next
Caption: week so you should come along if you're
Caption: interested um so really make sure that
Caption: that you really yeah making sure people
Caption: are aware of what to be careful of
Caption: things like when you're booking meetings
Caption: if you've got females that have to do
Caption: this to go pick up for the school
Caption: drop-off and they're not gonna be a with
Caption: be able to attend certain meeting with
Caption: scheduled meetings at that time of the
Caption: day like be considerate of that sort of
Caption: stuff but if people are aware of it they
Caption: can't be considerate of it so it's our
Caption: job as leaders to make sure that we're
Caption: providing that education I have a one of
Caption: my favorite memories of Steve McNally
Caption: who used to be who was a director last
Caption: year he's sitting in a management
Caption: meeting where I was there any female and
Caption: someone threw out a little assumption
Caption: that I was going to take the minutes
Caption: because you know that was there any
Caption: female right so who else would take me
Caption: that and he saw the look on my face and
Caption: he jumped in and was like it's all good
Caption: I would take the minute um you know he's
Caption: of a 12 year old daughter that he's
Caption: trying to get into IT so he's really
Caption: passionate about diversity and he
Caption: understands the biases that are there so
Caption: whatever things you need to educate
Caption: everybody on understanding that because
Caption: it will be a different organization if
Caption: people are aware of it same thing with
Caption: coffee right no one no one even tries
Caption: that I don't know it happens all the
Caption: time um and also perception around now
Caption: versus female you know sometimes it's
Caption: more appropriate men thing to get away
Caption: with interrupting or with being a little
Caption: bit aggressive but if a say my daughter
Caption: she's a so we need to be careful
Caption: around the perception and it's all an
Caption: education process it's just making sure
Caption: people are aware of these things and the
Caption: thought processes that happen without
Caption: you even knowing that they're happening
Caption: and call people out if you see people
Caption: during those types of behaviors call
Caption: them out I was in a last week I was at a
Caption: Whitworth event the Women in Technology
Caption: WH
Caption: event
Caption: and there was 35 women and there was
Caption: three men but came which is great
Caption: because we like men to come to those
Caption: events and everyone was looking for a
Caption: seat and one of the men said bull is
Caption: there a special seat to man like a
Caption: little bit kind of sarcastic and awkward
Caption: because it has been uncomfortable and
Caption: everyone sat down and the charity event
Caption: here said it's to everybody
Caption: guys I just want you to think for a
Caption: moment about how you feel right now how
Caption: it feels to be the minority and how it
Caption: feels to be the only man and this big
Caption: group of females and I want you to think
Caption: and just reflect for a moment on that
Caption: feeling of uncomfortableness and then I
Caption: want you to think that that's how most
Caption: of us working and I t feel every day
Caption: we're the one female in the 30 miles and
Caption: I just thought that was like
Caption: mind-blowing like it's so obvious but
Caption: until you reflect to think about it it
Caption: doesn't really sink in so cool people
Caption: out it doesn't have to be in a negative
Caption: way but call them out oh those little
Caption: snapshot up there of Sheryl Sandberg
Caption: because I really love her for cleaning I
Caption: don't know it was a little bit
Caption: controversial because she really puts a
Caption: lot of onus on females to step up and to
Caption: be more proactive which I agree with but
Caption: I think she also gives some really good
Caption: perspectives for men so I think for
Caption: those an females it's a great book to
Caption: read and just gives you some really
Caption: interesting perspective on some of the
Caption: things females go through that you just
Caption: wouldn't think about and I guess the
Caption: final thing I want to talk about is
Caption: people don't leave companies they leave
Caption: managers right so um you know it's all
Caption: about the leadership leaders need to be
Caption: proactive
Caption: you know Isis leaders need to step up
Caption: and we need to see the ones that
Caption: proactively encourage females if they're
Caption: not looking at the promotion processes
Caption: why aren't they we need to be really
Caption: proactive communication styles you know
Caption: making sure that if you're having you're
Caption: running a you know a boardroom meeting
Caption: and you've got females that aren't
Caption: speaking up make the effort and ask them
Caption: you know do you have anything that you
Caption: would like to input what do you think
Caption: about that kind of thing
Caption: my name right now but what are you
Caption: thinking about that um be proactive as a
Caption: leader you know they're like see that's
Caption: that's your job to to step up and to
Caption: play that role and be really proactive
Caption: as a mouth leader making sure that
Caption: you've got that you're giving fair face
Caption: time you know it's easy to assume that
Caption: you know females might not might not
Caption: want to go out for a beer after work why
Caption: wouldn't they
Caption: you need to make sure you're being
Caption: inclusive and that you're allowing
Caption: females to have the same rapport
Caption: building time and the same face time
Caption: with you that then male colleagues are
Caption: so so important and female leaders as
Caption: well we need to be really careful
Caption: because females are terrible at
Caption: comparing each other to other females so
Caption: you know I've been on both sides of the
Caption: coin where I've had a female manager who
Caption: definitely held me to a higher
Caption: expectation than my male colleague and
Caption: as a female I catch myself doing it as
Caption: well so you know we need to be my
Caption: leaders be really conscious about that
Caption: and I'd like to finish through the
Caption: practice what you preach certainly
Caption: throughout the interview process you
Caption: know be being open and honest and
Caption: transparent because when people join
Caption: your company they're going to find out
Caption: everything so you need to gain that
Caption: loyalty because this people can go work
Caption: anywhere especially in Perth ride you
Caption: can get another job tomorrow in about
Caption: ten places so if you want to retain the
Caption: loyalty practice what you preach the
Caption: whole way through and you will so thank
Caption: you very much for listening everyone
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: I beat you much longer any question
Caption: yeah I guess you know a perfect world
Caption: you use behavioral questions because
Caption: you're getting people to come up with
Caption: specific examples of things some people
Caption: struggle with local questions I
Caption: personally I'm not very good at
Caption: answering them I'm great at asking them
Caption: like I'm but euthanize the first point
Caption: and if someone's struggling you can help
Caption: them along a little bit so you know give
Caption: me an example of a time when you you
Caption: know were able to help how to colleague
Caption: with a situation that they were
Caption: struggling with you know they're you're
Caption: looking for teamwork right so take those
Caption: valleys and put them into examples of
Caption: how someone might be able to come up
Caption: with a story of where they've
Caption: demonstrated them passion for learning
Caption: you know tell me about how you go about
Caption: you know side of your work what do you
Caption: do what do you what do you do outside of
Caption: you work to increase your skills and to
Caption: you know to learn more things like that
Caption: so it's just really tying them into a
Caption: values faith question good question
Caption: yeah
Caption: as in you wouldn't want to ask that
Caption: question to someone yeah I think I think
Caption: it depends on what the response is right
Caption: so somebody said to me and this does
Caption: happen all the time so when I ask that
Caption: question if someone says you know what
Caption: like I've got a six month old and a
Caption: three year old and my life outside of
Caption: work is frickin insane so I actually
Caption: don't have a lot of time where I can
Caption: study but these are the things that I
Caption: get involved in or do within my work to
Caption: try and come back to that you know so I
Caption: guess it's just trying to that that's
Caption: fine if you would yeah I'm looking for
Caption: I'm just looking for that the glimpses
Caption: of that desire to learn and so how do
Caption: how do they improve this feel that they
Caption: can't do that side work that's totally
Caption: cool because I am all about work-life
Caption: balance themselves but then how are they
Caption: doing it what are they doing in their
Caption: work that keeps in that same thing you
Caption: do have to be careful